as I'm sure you probably know shooters
and bombers are overwhelmingly male and
yesterday we had an incident with the
rare rare female shooter a 39 year old
female ostensibly a youtuber although
she had a youtube channel that was
really quite small opened fire with a
handgun at YouTube San Bruno California
headquarters our YouTube rep works there
and I immediately reached out to him to
see if he's okay based on the profiles
published about the three victims who
were shot but all will hopefully pull
through I don't think that he was one of
them but this was right in there at that
San Bruno office where we have contact
I'm basically a weekly basis and she did
manage to injure three people one
critical one serious one not so serious
all taken to the hospital ultimately the
shooter was found dead from what
appeared to be a self-inflicted gunshot
wound and there are a lot of questions
around this early reports were that the
shooter actually asked for one of the
three victims by name which suggested
that she knew him at least to some
degree but then later police said that
there's actually no evidence whatsoever
that the shooter knew any of the victims
does that mean she never asked for
anyone or does that mean she did ask for
someone but that individual was not
ultimately one of the three people that
were shot I don't know but because she
was someone who uploaded videos to
YouTube it's conceivable that it was
someone she was in touch with for
YouTube related business we really don't
know at this point what we do know is
that some of the videos on her YouTube
channel which has since been taken down
were critical of YouTube itself and the
specific YouTube angle is actually a big
part of this the shooter had gone
missing previously and her dad called
the police was worried about her
indicated that she had been sort of
expressing rage at YouTube which
apparently was caused by YouTube no
longer paying her for posting videos
online unclear if that means the videos
individually were singled out for D
monetization or whether the entire
channel was pulled out of the partner
program she was eventually found in her
car about 30 miles from YouTube had
corners she believed that YouTube
employees were specifically reducing or
holding down the number of views that
her videos were getting encouraging her
to stop making videos whether that's
true or not we just don't know at this
point and as far as the victims at the
time they arrived at the hospital as I
mentioned one was in critical condition
one in serious condition one in fair
condition and we don't yet have more
news about that but I do want to talk
about the gender angle the gender angle
does stand out because in the u.s. as
I'm sure you know if you are paying
attention to the news with some
frequency most shooters or bombers or
whatever are young white men and when
they're not there either middle-aged
white men or they are young Arab men
often adherence to the Muslim faith but
predominantly in the u.s. young white
men women make up only 4% of mass
shooting suspects and that also is an
interesting angle because I'm talking
about the profile of mass shooting
suspects but what happened yesterday
depending on which definition you use
for a mass shooting might not even count
because mass shootings are often defined
as incidents where four or more people
are shot not including the shooter only
three people were shot here and I was
just thinking this morning as I was
reading articles and trying to learn
what happened how crazy is our world
where the reality is that when only
three people get shot in a single
incident it doesn't usually count as a
mass shooting it's not usually
characterized as a mass shooting and if
you go and look at gun violence
archive.org which keeps track of
incidents gun violence incidents and you
look at the number of shootings where
three people were shot you'll realize
that when you look at the quote total
number of mass shootings it is a drastic
understatement of what we might
colloquially understand to be mass
shootings because an incident where
three people are shot doesn't even count
as a mass shooting Donald Trump of
course sharing thoughts and prayers on
Twitter which at this point I don't even
know what to make of it Donald Trump
tweeting yesterday was just briefed on
the shoe
at youtube's headquarters in San Bruno
California our thoughts and prayers are
with everybody involved not much else to
say about that we've had sort of the
conversation about thoughts and prayers
as opposed to action when it comes to
guns and it's yet another example of
someone trying to solve a problem with
guns whether this was a real or only a
perceived problem that people at YouTube
were trying to prevent this shooter from
making money I don't know maybe will
sometimes find out but it's yet another
example of something that is
fundamentally a cultural issue it might
have mental illness components gun
safety components but the concept of
going and shooting because someone's
doing something to my YouTube channel
it's an interesting story and we'll see
how it unfolds but I was checking out
this woman socialblade profile she only
had about 12,000 subscribers maybe five
million video views which probably isn't
enough to make a living so losing that
amount of money that she was making
would not be a reason to go out and kill
people or yeah herself so it's it's
pretty bizarre yeah I mean we don't know
what other income she had we don't know
if she had another job we don't know
what percentage of her total income came
from the YouTube channel or what what
that income was and and I mean I would
argue that no matter how big one's
YouTube channel is losing the income
from their YouTube channel wouldn't be a
reason to go out and and deserve
shooting people we'll see what we learn
about this in the coming 24 to 48 hours
the video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership